hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation in vitro gen amina assays
vast choice of appropriate tools for
specific needs
presented by markus mijovich senior
manager research and development
antibodies and Amenia assays Thermo
Fisher Scientific I am sorry grenman of
laborat
and I will be your moderator for today's
events we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
lavage and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor
visit www.disabilitydenials.com for and
this offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
market mahalik I will now turn the
presentation over to him hi
everyone thanks for joining this webinar
on Invitrogen immunoassays so under the
trademark in retro gen some official
offers highly walid ated antibodies on
the one hand side and on the other hand
side it makes use of this great source
of in-house antibodies to develop high
quality immunoassays for research use
since for exploring all facets of the
immune system it needs both it needs the
antibodies on the one hand side to
analyze single cells for analyzing
different cell types and the immune cell
status by for instance visualizing
protein localization within cells or
tissues to help to decipher the complex
cellular processes and interactions and
it needs the immunoassays it needs the
immunoassays for analyzing the soluble
factors of the immune system analyzing
the soluble factors of the immune system
helps to understand the complex but of
course coordinated protein interactions
that sustain life and understanding this
crosstalk between cells and identifying
changes during pathophysiological
conditions may also help to understand
disease mechanisms
so there are so many many methodologies
available to scientists today and it can
be challenging to choose which tools are
the most effective to answer specific
questions we want to help you to choose
the appropriate tool for the specific
needs based on the decades of market
experience in the immunological research
regions market whether in the industrial
or academic segment we address the
different customer needs by different
technologies for detecting the same
analyzed dependent on the customer's
research focus dependent on the
application of product depending on the
customers funding situations for
instance or the technical experience of
the laboratory personal depending on the
status of a research project or even
depending on the instrumentation access
of the laboratory of the customer so in
consideration of these diverse
requirements in the scientific community
we have chosen to make products
available in a variety of different
formats for measuring individual
analytes
so we start here on the left hand side
of the slide with our so-called uncoated
eliza's a kind of match pair portfolio
you could say but it's much more than
matched pairs these and this uncoated
eliza's are provided in a kit format
with optimized regions so the coded
yourself
Eliza kids offer an affordable option if
you have less stringent requirements
then we have our ready to use pre coded
Eliza kids which are the high-end Eliza
formats the highly validated gold
standard immunoassays and then with the
instant Eliza is a further development
of the conventional Eliza instant Eliza
kids offer a uniquely streamlined
protocol to help save you steps and
hands on time still providing same
maximum accuracy and
usability and then we have our program
to me you know a circuits which are the
newest innovation for using small sample
volumes while achieving high sensitivity
and a large dynamic range protocol a
runtime is only two hours for these
program time essays and they the kids
come with all regions needed to run the
essays and can be read on a qPCR
instrument and finally our multiplex
platform of ricotta black sketch kits
which enable multiple proteins to be
measured simultaneously in one well so
the benefit of choosing from these
different platforms and formats all from
the same provider from thermo Fisher is
that the different platforms use same
antibody prayers for one analyte of
course we never technically feasible
which guarantees consistency and
scalability so it enables you to switch
from one platform to the other and
guarantees that you get same results in
today's webinar I will focus on our
latest innovation on the program
platform and explain how how this works
and in the second part on our
multiplexing platform the pro cataplexy
essays but before that
I would I have one slide on our
proprietary instant eliezer technology
so when choosing instant Eliza you are
still using the golden standard
immunoassay technology so the Elijah
technology while when using instant
Eliza you can dramatically increase your
Eliza productivity with as little as 15
minutes set up time only one wash step
and so you save up to one hour leverage
you have no laborious preparation of
reagents you have no serial dilution of
standards and you have knows the gradual
addition of si components to the plate
so how does this work in contrast to
conventional Eliza kids whose pre-coated
blades include only the capture antibody
when the sample is added instant Eliza
kids blades contain all of the necessary
components including of course the
capture antibody coated to the plate but
also live flies detection antibodies
reptilian age of be the sample diluent
and so all necessary components provided
freeze-dried on the plate
in addition trip wells containing the
standard for the standard curve are
provided separately so with the instant
Eliza kit you get the same as with the
conventional gold standard coated Eliza
kit so meaning same antibody pair same
optimized reagents illusion buffers and
other buffers but with the instant Eliza
kit all the preparation work has already
been done for you you simply rehydrate
add sample to perform a one wash SA and
you get same results as with a typical
Eliza but with a shortened workflow and
hands-on time
okay now with the next few slides I want
to introduce to you our innovative
next-generation platform next-generation
immunoassay platform called
program to
the program 'tom immunoassays combine
the best of both proteomics and genomics
technologies using proximity ligation sa
PLA technology the platform combines the
analyte specificity of a sandwich
immunoassay with signal detection and
amplification capabilities of real-time
pcr to achieve a powerful protein
quantitation tool so combining the
specificity of matched antibody pairs
and the sensitivity and broad dynamic
range of qpcr we end up with a
homogeneous no wash ese with high
sensitivity detecting proteins in the
Phantogram range with a broad dynamic
range of the 5 lakh unit with a low
sample consumption of 2 to 5 microliters
of samples needed only with a fast and
easy workflow asset this is a
homogeneous si sono wash step and only
two hours from sample to answer and in
addition you do not need any any
proprietary instrumentation so these
essays run on every common real-time PCR
instrument and on top we have developed
an intuitive brand-new cloud-based
software for a boost and easy analysis
so how do these essays work similar to
sandwich
Eliza's we again have an antibody pair
we again have an antibody pair two
antibodies binding to different epitopes
of the target analyte but in contrast to
analyzer where the antibodies are
conjugated to an enzyme or in contrast
to our multiplexing essays where the
antibody is conjugated to a fluorophore
in this case the antibodies are pre
conjugated to DNA oligonucleotides one
antibody is conjugated to a five-prime
oligo
the other one to three prime oligo when
the antibodies bind to the antigen it
brings the DNA oligo ends into close
proximity with the use of the
complementary splint oligo when the DNA
ligase the two strands like it to
generate a DNA template strand for
amplification then following a melting
temperature of 95 degrees Celsius
they're in active to inactivate ligase
the analyte and antibodies are generated
and no longer part of the essays
- and then this now is simply PNAS a
with 40 cycles of Technic you PCR for
detection and amplification of the
nucleic acids the amount of DNA is
measured after every cycle by a
fluorescent dyes the deal increasing
fluorescent signal in direct proportion
to the number of PCR product molecules
generated therefore with high
concentration of protein in your sample
which equates to high amount of DNA
template the cycle number to reach a
given threshold is lower the less
protein in your sample the more cycles
is needed to reach threshold with no
protein present in a well the CT value
is about 31 and with increasing
concentration of protein the CT values
decreases if you subtract the no protein
control value which is really background
from all the data points and plot Delta
city it is the beginning of the
predictable sigmoid our concentration
those dependent curve so once again
you in principle have two steps the
first step the classical immunoassay
part is the analyte binding where the
unknown sample and the antibody bodies
incubate for one hour in room
temperature and then once the antibodies
are bound and the two ends of the Olli
goes abroad in close proximity the
second step is the ligation and 40
cycles of qPCR in the qPCR instrument
once the run is complete the data file
can be transferred to the cloud EPS for
analysis
so this this cloud app this program Tom
saw fear is a step by step software that
also help helps you set up your essay
including standard curve dilution
calculation plate layout design and
customize label banner instruction once
the essay has been performed you simply
upload your run to the program team
cloud app and you can wanta PHY your
standard curve you can view your sample
results in pictogram family the
concentration for instance and also
perform powerful group wise statistics
and this cloud app is add-on and is for
free for all our customers
we have of course performed the typical
industrial standard validation tests
including parallelism linearity spike
recovery and of course the criteria and
specification which need to be fulfilled
are the same as for all our other
high-end immunoassay formats we have
also benchmarked the platform against
Eliza
as mentioned previously we try to use
same antibodies through all the
different platforms we have done this
benchmarking using natural samples to
show that the program essays perform as
expected
in summary the program team may enable
the research community to answer
questions and move forward in areas
where we may not have had adequate tools
in the past so we hope that we can you
that we can we can give you success
stories of our of our early adopters
very soon
because the first feedbacks we received
from the first tests on the market and
from the first customers using these
essays is really really positive
so in the next part of my presentation I
want to explain to you more about our
multiplexing platform which is the
so-called pro cutter plex
ASA's peccato plex is our Luminex
technology based multiplexing platform
for analysis of up to 80 analyzed again
whenever technically feasible we use the
same antibody pairs as we do for our
goals than the lyza
assays so choosing Pro kata flex you get
essays which are as specific as analyzer
but you get many many more data from
only 25 microliters of sample needed
within our pro cutter plex family we
offer three different platforms so we
have our standard Pro cataplexy essays
where we have the biggest portfolio
available for six different species and
the highest flexibility to mix and match
and to create your own custom panel we
have our pro cutter plex high
sensitivity essays based on our in-house
developed amplification technology for
multiplexing in Phantogram range these
are available for human and mouse and we
have our Platinum Pro cataplexy essays
which are optimized for human serum and
plasma samples and all three platforms
are available in several formats either
a simplex essays where you can combine
the simplex is you choose where we have
predefined panels as well or you create
your custom panel
and all these platforms and formats are
available for an almost complete
portfolio of cytokines and chemokines
many many growth factors but there were
so many other factors like correlation
factors metabolism markers we have
immune globulin either typing multiplex
assays for human mouse and read and many
many more
so one main focus in the last three
years of pro kata blacks development was
on the development of pro cataplexy
assays for immuno oncology biomarkers
what you see here is the so called
cancer immunity cycle somatically
showing in a seven step process how the
immune system fights against cancer
starting with the release of cancer cell
antigens after the cancer cell death the
cancer antigen uptake and presentation
the t-cell activation in the lymph nodes
and then the trafficking of the
activated t-cells to the tumor size the
infiltration into the tumor and finally
the killing of the cancer cells this of
course is the ideal scenario and we all
know that this ideal scenario can fail
and of course end up in severe diseases
each of these seven steps has a lot of
regulatory processes influenced by
stimulatory and inhibitory factors for
many of these factors we already had
multiplex panels on the market before so
we of course have a complete fourth
portfolio of pro and anti-inflammatory
cytokines which regulate this step two
we have a complete portfolio of
chemokines in the chitin factors that
regulate the t-cell trafficking and
infiltration so for the biomarkers in
immune oncology we focused on step
number three and step number seven so
the steps of t cell activation and
killing of the cancer cell exactly here
you also find the most important co
stimulatory and Co inhibitory molecules
which the cancer cell tries to influence
for their benefit by shutting down the
cancer immunity cycle
and these so-called check points have
therefore become the most promising
targets for immunity robotic drugs in
cancer treatment so beside already
approved to Munich Airport dick drugs
regulating for instance the ctla-4
checkpoint pathway or the pd-1
checkpoint pathway many others are in
clinical trials targeting these and
other checkpoint pathways
and in addition to the important role of
the adaptive immunity as shown in the
cancer immunity cycle also innate immune
cells especially NK cells contribute to
anti-cancer immune response and similar
regulatory processes and checkpoints can
be found during NK cell activation and
action so also here a lot of potential
targets are in focus for drug
development
most of these checkpoint molecules of
course unknown is membrane bound surface
molecules often acting as receptor
ligands for us and for the development
of such immunoassays it is important to
say that fallible either forms or shed
variants of these molecules are
described for a majority of these
checkpoint molecules and that these
soluble forms are not just cell
Deborah's but function for these forms
could be approved so they are
functioning either as immune adherents
or dhikr receptors and faster regulating
these checkpoint pathways this might of
course influence the clinical efficiency
of the individual checkpoint modulated
drugs and that this is the case and that
the detection of such soluble molecules
such soluble immune oncology checkpoint
markers might have a significant
relevance was shown in the publication
by Leung at all already in 2014 where
the group showed that the overall
survival after Eppley Mahbub treatment
is high in patients with high serum
city-level levels so serum city ll4
correlated with clinical benefits to
Ipanema lab treatment and the serum
levels for ctla4 in this study have been
detected or analyzed with
in vitro generalizer which we have
developed years ago so what we did we
took exactly this antibody pair of our
existing Eliza and brought it onto the
Prophet Oh Blake system in our
multiplexing system and in parallel
developed Pro Catholics essays for
twenty seven additional checkpoint
molecules regulating either the t cell
or the NK cell response to prove that
all these several forms of the
originally membrane bound molecules are
detectable in theorem we have screened
serum samples of melanoma patients so as
you see we we used seventy-two up to 160
different samples of different patients
and the data show results reported as a
mean of ungrouped human samples for all
targets included in our two immune
oncology checkpoint panels panel 1 and
panel 2 so we have divided these 28
different checkpoint molecules into two
panels but these two panels can also be
measured together so you can detect all
28 analyte in in one sample that you not
only see a kind of equal base level
through all samples we show in this
graph the results of individual Menem
individual melanoma patient samples
before and after treatment so these data
have been generated by one of our beta
testers and we have no insight into the
details of the treatment or the
treatment response but what is important
for us to see was that there is a
different level in this case for
instance for pd-1 but this is also true
for many of the other checkpoint
molecules included in our panels so the
level is diff
rent and the level changes during or
after treatment so the information we
get from this is that it might be
valuable to lick look into the serum
levels of these soluble checkpoint
molecules before treatment or monitoring
of these markers during treatment and
combine the data with clinical outcome
of therapy
in the next slide you see data obtained
with our immune oncology panel again
during another better testing which is
already published by our beta testers so
the detection level in this study of
several checkpoint molecules in samples
from human breast cancer patients before
and after chemotherapy are shown so six
immune checkpoint molecules were
detected with high levels in these
samples interestingly
CD 27g dat or PDL two which is CD 273
correlate it with the HMG b1 level and
were increased in human samples with
better response to chemotherapy and the
better five-year survival
and this is again data by another better
tester provided to us so again these
data show time-dependent changes of to
checkpoint molecules here so these and
previously shown results using the
immune oncology checkpoint panels and
one and to show different expression
patterns of the solo markers dependent
on disease states and cancer treatment
so the systematic similar Tannis and
analysis of these soluble biomarkers
should help to shed light on the biology
of these checkpoint pathways
and all this can be combined with our
monitoring with monitoring the immune
status with our biggest multiplex panel
on the market which is the sixty five
flex for monitoring the immune status it
is essential to look at as many of the
soluble factors Immelt Annesley
as possible and our immune monitoring 65
Plex includes all the important
cytokines chemokines growth factors and
as mentioned it is the biggest panel
available on this platform and with this
I can close the circle and come back to
the in vitro chance highly validated
antibodies which I mentioned in my first
slide because you can imagine how much
effort it is to bring two times 65
antibodies so 65 antibody pairs into one
reaction into one si into one panel
without having any cross reactivities
without having any interferences within
these 65 targets so the high quality
antibodies we generate and develop
in-house are really essential to end up
with such a such a big multiplex panel
so in my last slide I just want to
mention that we offer custom solutions
as well for all these platforms so if
there is for instance a target which you
can't find in our portfolio we offer
contract development of new essays on
each of the mansion platforms
we also offer measurement of customer
samples in our service lab if you do not
have the capacities the time to do that
by your own and many many more custom
solutions
so I hope I could give you some insight
in thermo Fisher scientific in research
and immunoassay tools and help to choose
the appropriate tool for your needs
thanks for choosing this webinar and
yeah I'm happy to answer your your
questions
Thank You Marcus Mahalo for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
do you have instant Eliza's for all your
Eliza targets and are the instant Eliza
the same price as the conventional
Eliza's so many of our key sites are
analyzers also available in instant
format but of course not all of them and
if there is a target you would like to
have as an instant format and you don't
find it on the web page please just
contact us so as pointed out in the
presentation we offer custom solutions
and we can work with you and discuss
with you how such a solution could look
like and regarding the costs so
[Music]
calculating the costs per sample the
instant Eliza is even cheaper than the
conventional Eliza so the kid price is
slightly above the conventional si but
you have more sample well so you have a
69 well plane for your samples and in
addition to that you have you have this
pre titrated standard curve in a
publication trip so you have more
samples and that means looking at the
cost per sample the instant is is even
cheaper than the conventional life great
thank you the next question is are the
amino oncology checkpoint marker
multiplex kits available for a mouse to
not yet but but they are in the pipeline
so so we have we have developed many of
these important checkpoint molecules
also for for mouse models also for the
mass system and the first smaller kids a
smaller panel will be launched in
October and the second panel in December
this year so they are coming soon
okay thank you the next question is can
I combine individual checkpoint markers
with some cytokines and chemokines to
one custom panel how can I find out what
is combined able and what is not okay so
finding out what is combined able 1 is
not is really easy so when you when you
go to when you visit the term official
web page and you look for Pro complex
immunoassays you will find a Picasa flex
panel configurator so you can there you
can design your own custom panel you
choose every target listed and all the
targets that we provide a listed there
and then the configurator want you if
the one or the other target is not
combined able so for the immune oncology
panels and principally principle for all
the new panels we developed with check
cross reactivity with every existing
target we do compatibility testing with
our huge 65 flex combining this with
every new developed panel and all the
information we we get from these
testings during development are listed
or our part of this panel configurator
on the website
I would like to once again thank Marcus
Mahalo for his presentation I would also
like to thank Thermo Fisher Scientific
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I would like to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2019 please share
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon
goodbye
hi